in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Don and
Elizabeth are with us welcome guys how
are you how are you blessed by the best
here you man good to have you welcome
welcome where you guys from
Simpsonville South Carolina and what is
that near that is near Greenville South
Carolina it's about 10 miles south of
Greenville gotcha okay welcome to
Nashville good to have you and you're
here to do a debt-free screen we are we
are absolute how much have you paid off
one hundred and ninety eight thousand
dollars love it how long did that take
forty three months good job and range of
income during that time started at sixty
up to about 85 now good good good now
was that your house that includes our
house we are we are as we are debt-free
we have zero eight latest zero degree
Alan told me forty three months ago that
this was going to happen we will be
standing here you could have pushed me
over hanging off the paying off the
mortgage that's wonderful
what's this house worth about a hundred
and ninety hundred ninety five thousand
it's paid for it's paid for they might
tell you how to paid for house
it's also that's pretty she went out
walked in the grass doing a doing
something else was doing what would I do
for a living so when I got home I walked
in the grass got the shoes it was
awesome grass feels different was very
cool very cool well very cool good to
have you guys so what happened forty
three months ago that puts you on this
journey
well actually happened forty nine months
ago okay Donald's late father was very
very sick and he was staying up with his
dad in Asheville North Carolina
my dad was giving me a ride back and
forth to Greenville to help me with we
have a special needs child to help me
get her to therapy and all that kind of
stuff and we were coming home one night
the cream he said let's listen today and
I said who screams and I thought that'll
never happen to us there's no way we can
do that and then in October of that year
instead passed away in June knocked over
I was under the couch cushions rolling
coins and headed by fifty six dollars to
five thousand
don't you know a little extra emergency
funds yeah we just started climbing from
there and you took off so you started
believing that could happen right
absolutely and it can't happen and then
and like you preach all this huh
you just gonna believe it yeah and
you've got to be you got to be
disciplined to be able to do it but it's
it is absolutely if we can do it believe
me anybody it's pretty impressive I mean
you guys knocked this out and you have
been on beans and rice for about four
years I mean well you buddy else so you
can live like nobody else yeah you
really are sitting here with a paid-for
house that's very very cool making sixty
to eighty five though to knock out one
hundred ninety-eight and forty three
months that's serious
did you sell anything or anything else
happened that's that's the other that's
the other thing is like you always are
preaching fine stuff that you can that
you can sell so we had a piece of
property that we had had in our
possession for what 22 23 years we sold
that off Oh God did that bring that
brought us about ninety thousand dollars
all the credit cards yeah okay don't
fail all the credit cards we had we had
some jewelry that we sell but she
actually started it before we did any of
that she threw the debt snowball and
we've paid off about twenty to twenty
five thousand dollars just right they're
really concerned until I wrote the debt
snowball out Wow as llamas that we
actually were in okay and then that gave
you like your wake-up call the shock it
was the wake-up call but you know we've
got and when we've we're at the point
now where we've got our six months put
away and you know we're we're just we're
as happy as can be right now you know to
be in a situation when you have extra
income every month and to figure out
what you can do with it you know the
other thing that we will tell you David
until your listeners tithe absolutely we
have found out we've been like she said
been married 32 years we have found out
when we have tithe it's unbelievable the
way that you see this you're blessed by
the man above by God when we don't tithe
we're not nearly as blessed tithe I mean
it is it is such an important biblical
principle and something that we have
just absolutely latched on to and try to
do and and now we're able to go above
and beyond the tie then it's great to be
able to give to other things that that
we're interested in and in seeing and
it's just a wonderful way you know
grateful
absolutely you live like no one else
later you can live and give I said oh
one else absolutely that says that there
is a principle there there's something
that happens when you give that is
spiritual it is mystical but it's also
really practical
it just it resets your brain absolutely
and I guess it takes your eyes off of
you for just a minute and I don't know
what it is I it but I've just witnessed
it all these years I've never had a soul
ever in all the years of doing this it
said I started tithing and my life it
ruined my life you know and never have
never heard that well it's one of things
that you're me it's a challenge yeah God
just lays it in front me test me in this
yeah see if it's see if it's true and it
helps to remind you that it's all his
anyhow yeah that's the reset your brain
centers you if you will back on what's
important and what's real well it's like
when Christ said hey you know love the
Lord your God with all your heart with
all your mind with all your soul but
also love your neighbor as yourself part
of loving yourself is realizing when
you've made bad decisions
it's correcting yourself you know it's
just realized that when you have done
something wrong and that was part of the
thing that we found out about being able
to pay off this debt it it wasn't
honoring God in any way shape or form to
to be a to be a servant to the master
other than other than tithing what do
you tell people the key was do you all
making this milestone of having your
home paid off in everything well of
Allah system absolutely there is baby
right there right there
I'm an impulsive shopper sometimes when
I'm out I'll buy things on impulse and
you're the only one in my check which
every time I see it on the statement I
go why did I spend that money on but
it's my I'm system but she asked me she
said what do you do when the food's all
up is empty I said I don't eat I'm down
did like $8 in my lunch envelope right
now so it'll be wonderful I got six more
days to make it through to the end of
June then I can reload there you go
sounds like some leftovers are in your
future that's all right right well
that's exactly how it's done right there
it sounds so common sense
because it is and yet it's not common
and you know you a midnight drive with
your dad and the strange man on the
radio and then all of a sudden you start
doing this stuff I'm so proud of y'all
congratulations thank you she sleeps
with you every night Oh careful now I
get I climb in bed and she's got her
headset on and she's got them you know
the today's Vaughn Crest and I'm you
know gave I'm being attributed with all
kinds of powers here that I just don't
have you guys are fun all right Don and
Elizabeth from Greenville South Carolina
a hundred and ninety eight thousand
dollars paid off in forty three months
making sixty to eighty five count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
he can carry a note I love it well hold
on you guys well done well done well
done fabulous oh hey that's fun sitting
there with a paid-for house Wow
what would you do to have your house
paid for would you say no to going out
to eat would you get on a written plan
what would you do
hey Don Elizabeth are neat people and
they're obviously bright people but
they're no different than you you can do
this stuff
they're proof that you can do this stuff
those debt-free screams that she used to
listen to in the car ride on the way
back with her dad they just did their
debt-free screen so when he's going to
yours when are you gonna get this moving
when are you gonna get out of debt so
that you can give like you want to give
so that you can invest like you want to
invest I'm telling you folks anybody can
do this stuff but you've got to want it
you know you can't keep doing the same
thing over and over and expect a
different result that's the definition
of insanity if you're gonna live like no
one else later if you will live like no
one else later you get to live like no
one else but delaying pleasure that's
one definition of maturity adults devise
a plan and follow it children do what
feels good and a whole culture people
doing what feels good well you don't get
to do what feels good when you're grown
up and grown up is not chronological
it's an emotional state it's a mental
health issue this is the Dave Ramsey
show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind